kiba prepared to deny the people the
freedom to choose whether they wish to
see the country become a fully fledged
member of the EU I want to sustain the
EU Veronica and as you say it's not my
priority to have a referendum whether we
should leave the European Union let me
explain why I think when I look at our
country I know what my priorities would
be as prime minister to tackle the cost
of living crisis to rescue our NHS to
build a future for our young people I
think leaving the EU be a disaster for
our country because I think we rely on
its jobs and and the trade we get from
being in the u EU I think strategically
for Britain whether you want to tackle
terrorism or climate change or a whole
range of issues we've got to be an
outward-looking country and so it's not
my priority now I have said and this is
unlikely to happen but I have said that
it is a transfer of powers from Britain
to the EU a further transfer of power
we'd have an in-out referendum there's
not likely to happen and that's what
leadership's about is saying what your
priority is I don't want us to leave the
EU so why would I call a referendum in
2017 and plunge the country into two
years of debate about something I don't
want to see how so just to clarify if
you win the next election you would not
call a referendum in that fight is
unlikely to happen I said that the lot
for the British passport I definitely no
it isn't no it isn't but of the criteria
I've set but I'm making no bones about
it case very unlikely to happen okay
I've said it's a transfer of power it
will happen but that doesn't seem likely
the moment that's a politician's answer
there isn't it well sure door seville
[ __ ] hello Neil